This is iPhone X.
Developing the form and display together defines a whole new integration,...
...making the boundary between the device and the screen hard to discern.
This new glass formulation, the most durable ever in a smartphone,...
...enables for the first time wireless charging.
Our new True Depth camera system, contained within this tiny space,...
...uses extraordinary depth sensing technology to let you unlock your phone with a glance.
We call this Face ID.
It maps the unique geometry of your face with over 30,000 invisible dots.
This data is analyzed by the neural engine on the A11 bionic chip,...
...the first of its kind.
Your iPhone now recognizes you, even in the dark...
...and will adapt to your physical changes.
This makes your face your secure password.
So, with just a look, you can authenticate your phone or use Apple Pay.